so the first hour was spent with a very
superficial SAR value of what I consider
some bass very basic properties of
thalamus and cortex I'm gonna use the
next hour this sort of get the more
complicated stuff that I find more
interesting it's gonna kind of ran them
there's not much organization of this
and I don't know how far I'll get and
some of the questions that were raised
in the first hour I might be able to
provide some answers to if I get there
so first topic has to do with inter
neurons and thalamus they're quite
interesting cell type and I think hope
that they demonstrate that to you and
they are organized in a particular kind
of synaptic arrangement that are called
try out so that's what I want to explain
so if we look at the cell types
typically that are found in thalamus
this is your relay cell big healthy
looking cell with a fairly large cell
body and somebody asks the question
afterwards and I forgot to mention it
the relay cells throughout thalamus
outnumber the inter neuron says that's
what this guy is by about three or four
to one throughout the Alamos with some
variability so these are about 75 to 80
percent and these are the rest okay so
this is the phenomena Kree ticular cell
GABAergic this is the inter neuron and
the relationship between these two
becomes quite interesting what I'm sorry
what they saw I'm sorry relay cells are
the cells that get input that's where a
Janicki let relay cell can input from
the retina project up the cortex if
their neurons do not they only innervate
these guys okay their innovation of
relay cells comes from a traditional
axon that provides a terminal output but
it's known as f1 the terminology there's
a reason for calling them F ones but
let's let go there it's not important
just that they have a particular kind of
output from the axial on that's very
traditional this is a typical kind of
XOR output you find in gabber
excels in cortex as well as thalamus
it's interesting as their dendrites
there's a blow-up also have these bulges
that look like synaptic terminals and
what we'll see is that most of the
outputs of an inter neuron so that the
gap puts come up from the axon but from
the dendrites here's a stain of an inter
neuron and these dendrites look like
axons with terminal arborizations if we
take a blow-up of this area here so it's
like an axon but it's actually a
dendrite with these clusters of
appendages they look like presynaptic
terminals that you'd find an axon in
fact they were a presynaptic terminals
so if we look at of the synapses that
come from these dendrites and by the way
I want to make clear how unusual this is
because if we go back to the neuron
doctrine and the idea that neurons are
polarized that the inputs come in the
dendrites get integrated and the axonal
output is the only output this defies
that this is a very different kind of
cell where most of the outputs are
actually coming from dendrites so this
is what one of these dendritic outputs
are doing and they engage in very
curious kinds of synaptic arrangements
and they're a couple of things about
this I want to emphasize and I'm using
as a first example the the kind of triad
we see in the lateral geniculate nucleus
get a retinal input and there are three
synapses involved here the retinal
terminal makes a synapse on to a relay
cell dendrite but also on to one of
these terminals from the inter neuron to
neuron then makes the third synapse on
under the same process that the retinal
terminal does that's why it's called a
triad 3 synapses so you get direct
excitation here and then direct
inhibition through this right is that
clear to everybody
there's an important variable here you
notice that this is glutamatergic
and it's activating only ionotropic
receptors mostly upper receptors here
but here it's activating metabotropic
glutamate receptors so even though it
the synapse and it synapses on both
structures because of the receptors
we're going to see there's an important
functional distinction here now this is
the case in the LGN if we picked any
Philomath nucleus we just take the
driving axon whether it could be medial
lemniscus if this were so essentially
and so on you get the same kind of
synaptic arrangement I have this sort of
purple cloud here we're calling that the
glomerulus mmm and explain why that's
also of interest although very poorly
understood we look at typical synapses
anywhere on a dendrite in cortex and
thalamus anywhere each individual
synapse is encapsulated by a glial
sheath now they're all the glial keith
is a sod one entirely clear was thought
among other things to prevent spillover
of the transmitter that's released from
this terminal to infect receptors
elsewhere that it soaks it up pretty
quickly but it probably plays other
roles as well and septic transmission
that are just been investigated but the
point is typically every single synapse
has this local lio sheath but in glory
kalimera listen thalamus and we don't
see this in cortex these individual
synapses are naked there's a glial
sheath around the whole thing and what
this may mean possibly is that
transmitter that's getting spilled out
from these terminals can spread much
further and have more effect beyond that
this has been a mystery for decades
people have tried to figure out what the
functional significance of this
difference is but we really don't know
beyond just guesswork like I have like I
offered so something is going on here
that we don't understand and I won't
have more to say about that because we
don't know anything more about it
the inter neuron itself is quite
interesting then and we think it's
multiplexing so we have on these
terminals that are both pre and
postsynaptic which makes them pretty
unique to be a synaptic terminal that
both is presynaptic to
the output to relay cells but also
postsynaptic to a variety of inputs not
just retinal and part of the equivalent
but also local axonal inputs from the
brain stem particular formation and the
axon of the inter neuron of other
interneurons and in these glomeruli and
approximately their inputs to the
proximal dendrites from retina and and
from other inputs mostly for brain stem
and this is the way we now think this is
a very unsophisticated model for how the
inter neuron is functioning but the
proximal inputs are controlling the
axonal output because these produce
epsps and ipsps that are going to
control the firing of the axon and
that's your traditional organization but
each of these represents a local circuit
and because of the very thin dendrites
that they emanate from and how distal
they are they have very very little
influence on neighboring ones and no
influence are very little on the cell
body
so we're multiplexing hundreds of local
circuits out on the dendrites and at the
same time the same cell supports an axon
with more conventional dealing with
inputs so this is what we think the way
the inter neuron is functioning any
questions about those yeah completely
separate as far as we can tell the
modeling suggests that there's some
experimental evidence that does show
that if you record from the cell body
and you can activate these chemically
you're not seeing any evidence for that
there they do seem to be electrically
isolated yeah that's a good question and
when I say those those experiments are
done in slices the possibility that
there's some active conductances in
these dendrites is there they haven't
been demonstrated but it may be because
these active conductances can be turned
on and off by blood Latorre inputs that
you don't see them in slices and only
see them in real animals so the
possibility is that this could have some
effect here under certain conditions
where modulation is allowing them to
happen but that's pure speculation
I understand cerebellum also has this
kind of why merrily of three are the
analogous of their glory a lot I don't
know about the sir the cerebellum but
the olfactory bulb has will very light
as well they're completely different
it's unfortunate that they have a
similar name I think let merrily is a
term that's used for complex synaptic
organization and that is very confusing
but not these kind of glomeruli as far
as I know don't exist anywhere else so
what if they're all be modulated by
different gamma frequencies and then
cell in the middle could listen to the
one it wanted to whoops
these are somehow oscillating I mean I
think gamma is on all that so most of
all the cells of FL we're not seeing
much evidence of that nor recordings and
I know that that these oscillations have
been reported and and do exist but under
the conditions we're looking at an R and
are behaving my so we're not seeing it
so I as a result of that because we
don't see it I can't tell you much about
it it doesn't mean it's not there and
doesn't mean it's not important but we
don't have a handle on it
okay so here this is trying to figure
out how to explain this what we think
the Triad is doing and this this may not
make much sense but it but it's based on
the fact that when the retinal axon is
firing it's activating ionotropic and
metabotropic receptors and remember
activating the ionotropic receptor has
done it even low firing rates but you're
not going to get this one activated
until the firing rate gets elevated so
we can imagine when the Triad is not
active and this and the there's a
contrast response function that the
contrast of a visual stimulus is is
monotonically related to the firing rate
of this axon that when there's not much
firing here we get a contrast response
function that looks like this because
the relay cell is getting at very low
levels just input that's from the relay
cell and and because the metabotropic
receptor here isn't activated this
circuit is shut down at low levels of
firing here so you get a very sensitive
contrast function but as we increase the
firing of the ret lakhs on we can start
to bring in more and more of this
circuit and when you do that you're
going to as you increase the firing here
you're going to increase in ambition
here and you're going to make this whole
process less sensitive and you have
basically adaptation of contrast here so
higher contrast the entire firing of the
retinal axon will bring in more and more
of the inhibitory circuit here because
of the activation of metabotropic
receptors requiring higher activation
levels and then if you were to shut this
off that contrast before it before the
contrast sensitivity reverted back to
its pre level would take about three or
four seconds that's because once you
activate them a Tabak trumpet receptor
here it's been shown in this system that
the activation lasts for about four
seconds remember these epsps
and then in this case it is an aps
P could last for several seconds to
several hundred several hundred
milliseconds to several seconds and here
it seems to be two to three seconds so
this entirely fits what we know about
contrast adaptation and evidence for
conduct contrast annotation to allow you
to be sensitive to the contrast range in
your environment with this kind of time
course has been demonstrated for retina
and cortex and the thalamus that we're
suggesting this is one way it could
happen in thalamus now this is
complicating the literature I did a very
good job of explaining it but any
questions about this this is just trying
to put some functional significance to
this curious triadic arrangement that's
found throughout thalamus including
human thalamus so when when you're in a
cold low contrast environment your
sensitivity contrast is pretty high if
you went from this room to a desert at
noon the contrast is much higher you
want to be less sensitive and this tells
you how it could happen because your
retinal input would be stronger it would
activate the inhibition here more and it
would reduce the gain of retina
genicular transmission
[Music]
if you just wanted to reduce the
contrast response it seems like you
could just you know turn down the game
of the neurons you could just sort of
act on the whole relay the the relay
neurons cell 4 is what is interesting
about this try a decoration or anything
from a computational point of view is
that you can you know you're modulating
information sent us by synapse right
gives you a great point game fine grain
control that you maybe you could do
something else if you if you try to
reduce the the game here by inhibiting
the neuro and globally you're affecting
all the synapses the nice thing about
this is it affecting only the Revel
input and that's what you want for
contrast adaptation I think I do and it
leaves the other setups as an effect
that their gayness unaffected so if you
want to modulate or do other things
you're not interfering with them the
other synopsis one like brain stem or
their cortical feedback that's what I
have to say about triads and intra
neurons and now I'm going to talk a
little bit about parallel processing
which is an important feature of at
least sensory processing applies to all
our sensory systems and this was hinted
at already in previous thoughts
particularly Jeff talked about this we
look at ganglion cell types and the cat
we have different kinds of ganglion
cells that have very different
morphology and very different physiology
the main ones that the first ones
described or called x and y this is why
the label here has been lost for x but
they have difficult receptive field
properties the Y cells have larger
receptive fields are more interested in
motion in lower spatial frequencies
these seem to be more dedicated to fine
details and less interested in motion
and what this says is that very early
levels in in retinal processing lease we
divide up information the visual seeing
in two different channels and this makes
more efficient processing the
information we also have a third cell
type called W again the X is missing
here and this has a garbage bag of cell
types it's probably the W cell was when
it was first defined was thought to be
unique cell type but now we think there
as many as 10 or 20 different cell types
subsumed under this classification
and that's still being worked out these
are party homogenious each but these
include cells that have the classic
center-surround organization as you see
annex of my cells other cells have a
fuse on and off zones that aren't
organized in the center surround some of
them are show direction selectivity says
and some of them so color sensitivities
so there's a wide variety of different
cell types that were plumbing together
as W but these represent separate
channels that come out of the retina and
we see the same thing in the monkey the
M cell called himself because that
innervates the magnocellular layers the
PCL innervates the parvocellular layers
of the LGN and the Konya cellular
cellular and these are equivalent
homologous specifically to y 4m x 4 P
and Antonio as equivalent to W it also
has a number of different cell types so
I get these separate channels coming out
of the retina and then the cap are
organized in the following way the x and
y cells innervate the a layers it's
laminated structure as you have in
humans and and monkeys the W cells
innervate the C layers of the the lower
C layers and the and Y cells only
innervate one of these c layers called C
magno so with large cells these are the
wise cells these are w cells this is a
mixture of x and y look at the mokey we
see a similar lamination pattern with
some details that are different the
parvocellular cells innervate the dorsal
layers 3 through 6 the magnocellular
cells innervate the ventral layers 1 and
2 the cony of cells the quorum of the Y
cells
terminate at the bottom of each of these
layers and that's for the co neo our
cells are found
I mentioned this just because parallel
processing again is is a feature of
visual processing and thought to be a
feature of other processing as well and
it's curious to me that this is a very
hot topic through the 70s and 80s in the
early 90s and people don't pay much
attention to this anymore
sure why because we want to understand
how sensory processing works we need to
understand more about how each of these
separate channels is handled
particularly at cortical levels and we
don't know much about that but again
here's here's a typical X element in the
cap this is data from the cap and Y cell
so even at the LGN level there's
different morphology for each of these
channels the same for the W but an
another interesting feature if we look
at the lamination and the cat is that
the x and y cells that are found then
the a layers and this layer here
I'll represent the core pathway from
from the algae and the cortex it's the
double yourselves that represent the
matrix pathway remember these are the
inputs that innervate mostly middle
layers of cortex this is the input that
innervates mostly layer one and we see
the same thing in the monkey the parvo
and magnocellular layers provide the
core input laconia say your layers
provide the matrix input so these matrix
cells are found even in the LGN the
innovate upper layers and we know so
little about what they're doing in
cortex I might add in the in the monkey
you will hear about
LGN innervating just area 17 or primary
visual cortex that's true the core input
but these matrix cells also innervate
many extra strike visual areas and there
and they a function of that is not at
all understood so how do these parallel
pathways operate through through cortex
do they that these pathways say step
right and and analyze each of these
channels of information independently we
don't know again because research on
this hasn't been very active in the last
20 years or so but the following
generalizations seem to be useful to
think about the two magno and parvo
pathway converge into v1 on two separate
layers so there even though they were
both in found in v1
the the Magnum parvo pathways are kept
separate in separate layers in the
process independently and there's a
dorsal stream of cortical areas that is
thought to be mostly involved in motion
and location in a ventral stream that
goes up in the temporal lobe of cortical
areas it's mostly involved in fine
detail and and shape discrimination and
there's a generalization that the dorsal
stream is mostly part of the Magna
pathway and the ventral stream more of
the parvo pathway although there's
evidence for mixture at all levels so
this is a gross generalization to
simplify things
coño we know nothing about so that's it
for parallel processing which is a
feature of a sensory processing thalamus
and cortex any questions about that
before I jump on I'm jumping around here
because there's no real organization I
won't say something about synaptic
numbers I think this has real
implications for Connacht omics and
present some real challenges there let's
consider the glutamatergic inputs that
innervate a genetic relay cell we think
of circuits on the brain in the
following way they can be divided into
glutamatergic inputs which we think
carry the main information and modulator
inputs like cholinergic and so on that
are modulating those circuits and
gabbard it that provided ambition can be
thought of as this different kind of
modulation but here we have two
glutamatergic inputs that as we'll see
have very different functions if they
want to ask the question what do these
inputs as providing the main information
to the relay cell to be relayed to
cortex we can get an answer to that by
studying the receptive field properties
of each of these units because how a
cell responds to its visual stimuli
tells you a lot about what kind of
information it's able to pass on to its
postsynaptic targets well the receptive
field of the retinal output we know is
the classic center-surround organization
and these receptive fields are monocular
meaning only the
I of origin of the Retel axon can drive
them stimulating the other I will have
no effect on them so that's the
information coming in what about the
information that might be coming from
layer six of cortex these receptive
fields and we're complicated
they have binocular receptive fields
some stimulating either eye in the
appropriate area can cause a cell to
fire
they have specificity not seen here for
orientation for direction and for many
other features these are much more
complicated receptive fields in these we
want to know which of these is the input
that that is being used to inform relay
cells we could ask what the receptive
field with real a cell is and it's the
same as a retinal input this has been
known for decades and this is why we say
that the LGN is relaying rental
information of cortex that's pretty
clear and unambiguous for that reason
we're calling the rental input the
drivers because that's the main
information that is being used here
which raises the question what's going
on here why do we have this other bloom
a third input with this kind of
information that is not clearly seen and
what's being fed up to cortex well for a
lot I don't have time to go into this
but we're calling this a modulator
because it behaves very much like
classic modulator is called nergic and
so on with one important distinction the
classic modulator systems are very
diffusely organized and seem to be
related to overall behavioral State the
glutamatergic modulators are the only
ones that have a great deal of
topography and we need topographic
modulation for such things as spatial
attention adaptation and so on and only
the glutamatergic modulators seem
organized in a fashion to do that anyway
we do have these differences now we're
going to see how these inputs are
organized on to the relay cell so we
have two examples here
data from the cat but this applies to
the rodent as well we don't have data
from the monkey but hopefully because it
applies to the cats and rodents it
applies to monkeys this where we
collapse the dendritic tree into a
single dendrite and it shows the inputs
and where they're located in roughly
proportional numbers so we see cortical
input off
here input from from Terran axons out
here and closer to the cell body we have
a retinal input and internal inputs
remember this is the triad
that we see an equilibrium of some it's
interesting that these are only related
to X cells are not to Y cells so Y cells
have a very simple way of getting rental
import across to the real a cell rose
and neck cells you have this complex
triad that may play a role in contrast
adaptation what about numbers the rebel
input the one that we think is so
important provides only about 5% of the
synapses on the dendritic tree the
cortical input provides almost an order
of magnitude more these are the numbers
for other inputs if you just wanted to
think about going to matter Jake inputs
thinking the glutamatergic inputs are
the main information we're out there and
think of the brain organized in some
sort of democracy for dendrites and used
connect ohmic data that would give you
these numbers you would come to the
conclusion that what's being relayed
here is provided by the cortical but
because it's so much more than the
retinal input and the retinal numbers
are very low and probably not very
significant that's because we have
functional data that we know that's
wrong this is the important input and we
know from synaptic properties that you
can't get just from Anatomy but these
provide very powerful synapses and they
provide very weak synapses which is part
of the answer to this what I'm saying is
if you just rely on synaptic numbers or
even axonal numbers and pathways you can
be very badly misled and I submit that
you would definitely be misled if you
try to use that strategy for the
thalamus and I believe the same holds
for cortex but the driving inputs in
cortex that are equivalent of retinal
inputs are very small in number compared
to their modulatory glutamatergic in
but numbers in cortex are much harder to
obtain it we don't have good data for
that notice also the dendritic tree on
where the inputs are coming in Jeff made
the point a couple days ago that there's
surprising specificity in the way
individual axon will target some cells
and ignore other dendrites from other
cells even though they're physically is
close their specificity in cell to cell
contacts but the specific specificity
goes even further than that of course
there's a cortical zone
that's innovative and a retinal zone
that's innovated and they don't overlap
at all and furthermore for inhibitory
inputs the TRN inputs or distal the
inter neuron inputs are proximal and
they don't inter they don't overlap this
is saying that the specificity for these
contacts apply not just cell to cell but
what area of dendrites that are
innervated and the significance of this
isn't entirely clear but there's a very
dramatic observation of the way these
circuits are organized any questions
about that
which one yes so X is equivalent to
parvocellular y de magnus and when I say
equivalent I mean homologous and that
has implications for for evolution and W
and Coney are or homologous yeah just
get a quick like how many how many
neurons are firing between retinal input
to v4 like is it like 3 years I'm not
sure what your question if you have a
photon hit a photoreceptor retinal there
on fires like how many steps oh how many
synapses DF go across okay so the the
retinal input you know the retinoid you
go from photoreceptor to bipolar cell
the gaming cell Dainius out of
geniculate sell tickets L to v1 and you
can go from v1 to v4 you know V from v1
MT it can go from v1 directly to lots of
areas
another possibility is you can go from
retinal ganglion cell to the co neo
cells were double yourselves and get
directly to be to v4 from from the algae
but we don't know what that pathway is
doing you know you know what that
corresponds to in terms of timing like
roughly what's interesting is that
we think of that this is just one
example of why that's so surprising and
hard to understand v2 and the monkey is
higher order than v1 but if you look at
latency to visual responses most
responses in v2 actually happened before
v1 and one explanation for that is that
the axons that are innervating that
pathway in the v2 are coming through the
magnet pathway which has much faster
conducted velocity whereas the responses
in v1 and domino and they were by the
part of our pathway beyond that I don't
think we know a lot about latency if we
get there's another point I may get to I
want to bring that up again because I
think latency is an important issue but
to me very very confusing I'm not sure
what it means in fact I'll get to it
here so now I want to talk about
transatlantic cornica cortical
processing and this is a new circuit
that we're very excited about that
ten years or so ago wasn't known much
about but now where we and other labs
are studying it and it goes as follows
I'm going to compare to fill a McNew
CLIA here the LGN and the pulvinar now
the pulvinar is the largest thalamic
nucleus it's roughly 30 to 50 times
larger than the LVN by volume and the
size difference here is important I
think both are visual relays we know
they're out the LGN is visual because it
relays retinal information the pulvinar
we think is visual because remember I
said cortex has about 36 areas that are
visual areas pulvinar innervates all of
them are so we know what the pulvinar
innervates but the question is what is
driving the pulvinar oh so the algae own
and the pulvinar both have the same non
driving input input from local GABAergic
cells input from the brain stem
reticular formation descending input
that's feedback from layer six it's
modular Tori we think the driving input
from lgn comes from right now the
mystery for a long time is what the
driving input the pulvinar is the
driving input in ret
often occupies glomeruli with large
terminals or proximal dendrites and
those were defined and described in
pulvinar decades ago but the mystery is
what the source of these synapses that
were seem to be driving synapses and now
we know from research on a number of
labs that the origin of this input comes
from layer 5 cortex so they have
something very interesting here
automatic relays get a feedback from
layer 6 of cortex that's module Ettore
but the pulvinar in addition of that
cortical input gets an input from layer
5 of cortex that's organized in a
feed-forward manner what a feedback
manner and this pathway functionally and
anatomically looks very much like
retinal impact algea so what we think is
going on here as if the pulvinar serves
to relay information from one cortical
area to another so we're calling the
algae on an exemplar the first order
relay because it relays information for
the first time visual information in
this case the cortex calling Palvin or
an exemplar of a high order relay
because it's relaying information
authority in cortex but from one
cortical area to another another way of
looking at is the first order relay get
their information from subcortical
sources from retina from the medial
lemniscus of it somatosensory from
inferior colliculus if it's auditory
whereas the higher-order relay gets its
driving and putting up from a
subcortical source but from later v of
cortex and this high order relay that
can relay information from a primary
area to a secondary area it can keep
going as well as off as much as you like
there's lots of bandwidth theater
because remember the pulvinar the LGN
just does this once the pulvinar can do
this for 30 some areas on the pulvinar
is 30 to 50 times larger than the LGN so
the anatomy here matches at least in a
crude way to enable it to do that now
this first and higher-order
division where the higher-order relays
are actually relaying information
between cortical areas to see not just
in the visual system but also there's
the
somatosensory system VPM an owl or the
first-order relays equivalent to the LGN
relaying the mystical information cortex
the posterior medial nucleus is the
equivalent of pulvinar the ventral part
of the medial directed at is relaying
auditory information from the inferior
colliculus that's the first-order
auditory relay the dorsal division of
the medial genicular is a higher R to
relay and so on and when we look at the
Loomis as a whole it turns out as this
which would suggest that most if a
Loomis whose function was kind of
mysterious because we didn't know what
information was being relayed most of
thalamus turns out to be higher-order
and so we can ascribe a fairly
straightforward a suggestion for what
must a thalamus is doing like the
Pullman or it's relaying information
between cortical areas these pathways
exist but what's curious is that there
are also direct connections between
these areas it's a very curious
arrangement that seems to generalize
although we don't know if this is
completely true in all cases when
there's a direct connection between two
cortical areas there's a parallelism
that are there devolves thalamus a very
curious arrangement but this is based on
a relatively small number of examples in
the mouse a few and Caplin few and
monkey we really like to get many more
examples to see how general this is and
this raises a number of questions before
I get to that there's another curious
anatomical point these axons that
provide the input to be relayed both for
first and higher-order are branching
axons and they all send a branch to
other structures in the brain stem
not just the thalamus and many of these
structures or motor centers like the
superior colliculus or the rubriz red
nucleus structures that are involved in
super spinal control and I probably
won't have time to say much about this
I'll just throw out the anatomical fact
that needs some explaining so there this
raises a number of questions how common
is the parallel organization of direct
and transonic pathways
cortical functioning or how often do you
get tears of cortex connected just
directly or just through the thalamus we
don't know but the examples we have
suggests that this parallel organization
is at least common what is different
about the information that's going
direct as opposed to through thalamus
there's only different kinds of
information are being sent through each
pathway and what is the difference and
why is one process through thalamus
instead of going directly what's special
about that information room that it
takes the thalamic group and finally
what is the significance of these
branching axons these are the four
questions that we and other labs are
trying to get a handle on and that's
pretty much where I can leave it for now
and maybe some discussion later but
slightly different this road that no for
example you know kind of prepare for
visual tasks or so that it activates a
small subset of cortical areas and also
office space may be a common resume so
in those so pulvinar pulvinar can can
because poet or innervates all the areas
groups of povo know and we don't know
what the mapping is from Poland or at
each of the quarter careers which makes
it very difficult to study you've
imagined there are thirty some-odd
different maps in Colvin or depending on
which cortical areas are both targets
and input areas now by this view these
pulvinar cells are just relaying
information they're getting from layer
five of cork that's just like genetic
cells are relaying rental information
they're not doing with processing here
but the processing that's significant is
taking place in cortex and you can
imagine anything you want that look at
different cortical areas through their
layer five outputs which have already
processed this important information
through pulvinar are organizing
different cortical areas another way of
looking at this is that imagine that a
cortical area innervates
ten other quarter couriers directly and
and through thalamus and the reason you
send things through thalamus is you can
block it here and what's going to be
important for how quarto car is
communicate is which areas are
connected by both and which areas are
connected only by the direct route and
this is where pulvinar can play a big
role because whether Poland or his gate
is open or closed can determine what
combinations of cortical areas are in
contact and cooperating lots of
possibilities
lots of questions but those are just
speculations it's a sense of all
recording suggested specific shutting
down and turning on yeah we think this
is pretty global that they that the look
that they control of the gating that
you're talking about we think mostly
comes from a layer six feedback let go
that speculation there this is fairly
new and and trying to understand how it
works you can imagine all sorts of
hypotheses that need to be tested add to
that question leads to questions can we
say something about the different
latencies of these signals yeah I'm glad
you asked because if you if you go from
v1 to v2 that's a pretty short pathway
and if you go from v1 to v2 near their
verdict near the mapping of the fovea
that pathway is very short short latency
if you go from v1 to v2 and in areas
that are mapping 15 degrees out it's
much longer pathway so the latency is a
we think there would be very different
if you go down a pulvinar and back up
again
you have the same route same latency and
that's interesting and it's also those
are the fastest conducting axons in the
brain are the ones going down the
pulvinar and back up so we think these
trans lamech pathways whether they're
going from v1 to v2 or v wind MT which
is very far away have a constant latency
but the direct routes are all over the
place and latency I don't know what that
means but the and so suppose you have
area just area what so its job is to
represent information but also it also
has to ask question
like is that where's the red red on my
retina so that's the question then I
have to pull the thalamus and so now we
go to error area to now area two has a
question so it has two ways to do it you
could translate the question into
something that area one understands or
you could just replicate the entire
circuitry that has its elements in there
and so now the but area one it's
representation is now input so that gets
to put that that's sent to the area mm
us and so area two could ask its
questions directly in the same way that
area one has it's questions and so so on
up to the other brother various followed
that but if it's just but you do do we
do do you do have two very different
things you do when is you you build
these representations of simple cells
blah blah blah but having noses you're
not done you just creating a data
structure that you can use to do things
like you can in the official routines a
la brasa mother where you're constantly
pulling the representation that you have
to figure out things and so you won one
way of doing that is what what school of
thought is that the way you do that is
you actually ask them boundless because
of that everything else has always
finite fine detail stuff down there that
depends on what kind of circuitry you
think what product processing is going
on in the thalamus which I will say is
an open question the very simple way
we're looking at it which may be too
simple is that what's going on here is
the same as it's going on here meaning
that's not much processing you have
mostly a gated relay and that means that
what this information that's being
passed along is basically a copy of what
what's being processed through the layer
five outputs in all of these areas what
you want to do with that I think there
again you can speculate and come up with
all sorts of interesting hypotheses that
to test them and we have our own
hypothesis we have a different view of
what this is all doing
but it's speculation that there's no
better than anybody else's but that's
what we're trying to figure out okay yep
are there any loops in this you have
that you said it's off before but it
could be that Arianne feedback to area
one
there probably are loops but they
haven't been identified and there's a
interesting paper that Francis Crick
wrote in the late nineties that called
the long strong loops hypothesis that
suggests that you shouldn't have strong
driver loops going you need circuits we
haven't seen any negative data doesn't
mean a lot at this point good question
about this concept every relay said it
would share using quite often so if it
has a connection where one synapse comes
into the relay cell and then there's
really a set up from some other
connection to some other said than a few
little relays but I guess actually relay
cell gets input from many neurons like
1500 bronze so therefore it's maybe not
just relaying information but
integrating information right so the
question so let's take the retina for
example it gets convergent input in the
cat monkey from very few Retel axons one
to six but it gets lots of input from
Hunt from more than 100 cortical axons
but we think those are modular toriel
they're not providing the information to
be relayed and that's based on receptive
field properties whether these pulvinar
cells are getting similar to to the
algae and getting input from just a few
layer five cells with very similar
properties as you get here and the rest
of these inputs are modular Tory which
plays an important role but a different
kind of rule that's one possibility
the other is that these cells may be
getting maybe integrating input from
layer 5 of multiple areas that would be
a different kind of rule that we don't
foresee for lgn that's a possibility
that was one of the questions it was
also being asked whether that sort of
integration occurs in structures like
pull the door I think it's still an open
question
are there clears anatomical subdivisions
yeah so here's a big problem
imagine you record from a cell and
pulvinar you stick your electrode in
there get a receptive field and now
someone another level ants are
replicated if we're right the pulvinar
has 36 areas that haven't been
identified or mapped out I can't tell
the next lab exactly what part of
polymer is recording from was I
recording from a cell that got input
from v1 or a solid got input from mt and
that makes it very difficult because we
don't know what the map is and that's
one problem with Pavan or that people
have done recordings but each lab has a
completely different set of results you
can imagine these receptive fields would
be very simply simple because they're
getting the input from layer 5 cells of
v1 but cells getting their input from
some parietal area could have very
complex receptive fields the other
problem is people have made lesions in
pulvinar 12 adore about cell GN so
everybody makes their lesion away from
the LGN they want to make small lesions
and the same problem exists a lesion in
one lab probably doesn't affect the same
circuits as a lesion another lab so you
have results pulvinar lesions all over
the map suddenly the blindness some lead
to very little and it's a real problem
because we don't have a good map of
Pavan or in a good way of knowing when
you're studying a part of pulvinar which
of the circuits of cortex you're
affecting
area of cortex as opposed to maybe
getting multiple areas that was the show
they promise good these circuits are
important as a single cell level
pulvinar gets input from all these
cortical areas but we want to know how
single cells are whether they're
integrating and put for multipliers and
we don't know the answer to that okay
yeah as far as I understand the thalamus
exists in essentially all the
vertebrates including primitive ones
that don't really have much in the way
of cerebral cortex right that's a great
question from an evolutionary point of
view there's a lot of debate about
whether the structures that are occur
that have been defined in in fish birds
and reptiles or homologous to the
thalamus or analogous and I think in the
bird the data is best in the bird I
think the data and the bird suggests
that what is described as thalamus
really is homologous the thalamus the
question is where's cortex if that's the
case and there's structures in the teal
encephalon of the bird that for years
were debated whether it were they
homologous to cortex are they basal
ganglia and only recently using
molecular techniques in the last five
years or so there was a definitive
answer to that that there are cells
individual cells in the telencephalon of
the bird
there are Mulligan stew neo cortical
cells but this but they're not organized
in layers are organized in nuclei so
this is a group of layer 5 cells here
another group of layer 4 cells here
beyond that we don't know much so
there's the seem to be a foul missus
does seem to be cortical structures and
there is there are pathways between them
the function is in some sense the same
yes and no the whole point of
evolutionary members to take a
homologous structure and provide
different functions for it so saying
they're homologous does not imply
necessarily they have the same function
I think that's an open question
I don't hear you I'm sorry most of this
evidence for translating pathways comes
from the mouse there's some scattered
evidence on the monkey and uncap but not
those kind of detail so we need many
more examples and particularly nice to
have more for the monkey the monkey may
have some evidence that v1 to MT has
both direct and trans lemak penetration
and some evidence the v1 to v2 but even
the evidence that exists in the monkey
isn't as good as you would want that you
have on the mouse I think the hypothesis
is that this is a general feature of
cortex that applies to to primates but
it has to be tested them hasn't really
been resolved for it hasn't been
resolved well outside of the mouse right
now
sorry so my question was about like
whether there's any evidence for defeat
oh right so that's I have this as a
feed-forward there's actually and that's
something our lab is working on whether
there are feedback pathways that did the
same thing we think there are but we
don't have evidence we don't have good
evidence for that yet so may go both
directions it's interesting that the
feed-forward pathways are all driver
information-bearing but the input from
pulvinar to v1 is all modulatory just
like the later six input to the LGN so
there may be feedback modulation going
through
I'm pretty much done so let me just go
through these conclusions and there
won't be some extra time for questions
of people still have them first I talked
about corn matrix lemak Oracle systems
I'm bringing it up again even there are
no much I can tell you about it
just keep in mind that the matrix
pathways do exist and they're mysterious
we don't know much about them and from a
research point of view anybody who's
interested in this is a really rich area
turret to to study are there other types
of planet cortical projection so I loved
these as two types called corn matrix
but there is some anatomical evidence a
neuro anatomist named Francisco Alaska
from Spain has provided evidence that
that there are flama cortical
projections that don't fit neatly into
the core matrix pigeonholes and that
there may be other kinds of
fundamentally different flem a cortical
projections we've all focused on the
core pathways with some knowledge the
matrix exists but this may be too much
of an oversimplification details of
circuitry are important and I try to
make the point with the example of the
layer 6 feedback to 2 thalamus that it's
one thing to say that the pathway
innervates relay cells and inhibitory
inputs the relay cells and it looks like
it's organized as a direct from from a
pathway point-of-view a direct
excitatory and indirect inhibitory
circuit but that probably isn't how it's
actually organized and to get at that at
the real organization requires
understanding the circuitry at the
single axon level which is almost never
done and most studies experimental
studies that study the functional
organization of pathways either activate
or inactivate or swaths of a of a source
input and I try to show by example in
the layer 6 feedback how that can be
very misleading it's a problem I know
there's a good solution to it but I
think
you need to be aware of the problem the
other detail that's important and this
is a concern for connectomics is that
numbers can be very misleading again if
we take the LGN if you just use numbers
of synapses in this circuits you come to
the wrong conclusion about what relay
cells were relaying what kind of
information they were relaying and we
don't we have good evidence and that
this is true throughout thalamus that
the information coming in to thalamus to
be relayed to cortex whether it's from
layer 5 whether it's from retina whether
it's from the medial lemniscus
represents 5% or less of the total
number of synapses and that the other
glutamatergic inputs from cortex from
layer 6 have an order of magnitude more
synapses and the tendency I think still
of people when they analyze circuits is
to use this democracy point of view that
the more synapses the more axons are
more powerful more important frankly I
think that's wrong not just for thalamus
but also for cortex you have to identify
the functional properties of the inputs
which right now you can't do just from
Anatomy hopefully so in the
not-too-distant future we'll have
anatomical tags for the different kinds
of glutamatergic input driver versus
modulator so that you can figure out and
really follow us follow information
flowing circuits another point is
metabotropic receptors they're dominant
I mean they're not dominant some world
where they're found widely through
thalamus and cortex and in cortex we've
estimated in the mouse at least that
most glutamatergic pathways within
cortex activate metabotropic receptors
it's a subset that doesn't fit some
minority but that don't pay too much
faith in that because well that's true
and talents and we have good numbers for
it we're just starting to accumulate
these numbers in cortex what I think I
can say with some confidence is that no
matter Jake pathways that activate
metabotropic receptors and cortex are
sufficiently common to warrant
consideration when you're modeling
cortex and this provides some very
different functions what other thing I
may point out there's a long literature
for plasticity that says that things
like LTP that we used to think was
dependent just on NMDA receptors in
cortex are many cortical LTP examples
that are dependent on NMDA receptor oh
no and metabotropic glutamate receptors
and not NMDA receptors so they probably
play an important role in cortical
circuitry not just an overall function
but in plasticity and one last thing
I'll point out all cells that we know of
with alamos and cortex have
voltage-gated conductances that can be
turned on or off depending on membrane
voltage they play a very important role
for how the cell responds cortical cells
for instance a layer 5 can burst or not
burst depending on which whether a
particular calcium conductance activated
or not but to change the activation
level of all these conductance is a
sodium channel and the action potential
is a is it as a an example of one that
doesn't do this but almost all other
conductances you have to change the
membrane potential by a little bit five
or ten millivolts in the other direction
to effect this change but that change
has to be held for at least hundred
milliseconds to switch the channel from
activation to inactivation and
autotrophic receptors are too fast to do
this it's the metabotropic receptors
when activated they can change membrane
potential for hundreds of milliseconds
that we think are key to controlling the
which ion channels are going to be
inactivated or activated in cortical in
thalamic cells
mostly lamech synapses and we think this
is true of cortical synapses I said are
not information-bearing again this gets
the point of parsing circuits based on
total numbers I can be very misleading
they're all processing is this
throughout the Alamos how far you can
you can carry this in cortex um still I
think an interesting question but
frankly one that's not a very hard issue
at the moment existence of trans limit
cortical cortical pathways we think is
an important new way of looking at
cortical function these pathways do
exist details of what they're doing
and why you have a transatlantic route
is supposed to direct routes or I think
I arranged those questions so I'm gonna
leave you with a try on a higher level
we'll bring some more into this this is
a painting on a very famous painting in
the Sistine Chapel by Michelangelo and
the title was giving spark of light to
Adam or something like that I can
remember the title but apparently the
title was not Michelangelo's he never
named us and the idea that God is giving
life to to Adam something that
Michelangelo never suggested
Michelangelo was an interesting man
because he was very interested in
anatomy anatomy was something important
for him for painting and four sculptures
obviously he was a grave robber he took
as many bodies as he could to study them
and dissected them and that led to a lot
of his art work but I was particularly
interested in the brain and it was
probably the world's foremost
neuroanatomist of his day when he could
take him when he could get a brain in
good condition he took it out of the
skull dissected didn't try to identify
structures the reason all of that is
interesting is that if you look at this
picture from a slightly different point
of view you realize that this is the
brain there's a pioneer named spinal
cord this is cortex so the idea and
other interpretations that like is that
God is not giving Adam life of giving
him intelligence
and the final point I'd note is that God
sitting here in the brain
sitting that's a stroke and so he
recognized that it was very important ok
I'll leave you with that thought
[Applause]
don't ask me questions about God please
their other agreeing for Michelangelo
yeah yeah what what's your question
about there oh this is something that
they taught my idea this is um there's a
literature on let me just since you
asked give you another example here
okay so here's another one of his
paintings it's also the Sistine Chapel
look at this region here here's the
brainstem the thalamus if you look more
closely this is these are the two eyes
the optic nerves coming together at the
optic chiasm he embedded parts of the
brains of many of his paintings and he
didn't get a very sneaky manner I never
say anything about this so all of this
idea that he was putting brains on his
paintings is fairly recent not buying
other people have written about this but
I I think that's kind of interesting
right he was in many ways a man ahead of
his times question yeah just a very
overall the Chairman so you've given a
lot of directions or research questions
with a thorough physiologists and this
audience what role could the Computer
Sciences play and then you know and I
think you did a nice job of really
giving the dichotomy between functional
and anatomical work and I think the
computer science is sort of really play
a role in the functional eyes
so I just want to know what your
suggestions to us yeah I think it's a
great question and maybe the point of
all this whole semesters to try to
figure these things out I'm right I
think there a couple of issues I would
raise but I don't have really good
answers for how they would be
incorporated one is that when you're
modeling circuits say in cortex
I understand any of these models is that
they if you have synapses involved the
of a simple alpha function that would be
basically modeling what ionotropic
receptors are doing in these circuits I
would like to see metabotropic receptors
brought in having said that I would also
acknowledge that we probably don't
understand them well enough to figure
out how bottles would make use of them
but I think that to the extent that we
really want to understand cortical
circuitry or any other circuitry that
that metabotropic receptors have to be
understood and incorporated the other
thing I would say is when I see models
the ones that I'm familiar with Tim to
treat circuits again as some sort of
democracy and that strength is based on
inputs and I think that's wrong but
again having said that I don't have a
good answer for I you deal with that
because we don't know how to identify
one versus the other but maybe models
can be made explicitly with these two
kinds of inputs to come up with
something more interesting I guess those
would be my two main points
I also wondered about this question and
I want to propose a hypothesis that
knows I think almost all models that I'm
familiar with at least when they come
from a Catholic home computation
computer science background they really
focus on a single computation of oration
a single task like visual processing and
so therefore this models may not need of
telomers from the functional perspective
as soon as they would model now a system
that can solve many different tasks
depending on the environmental demands
then you maybe need a control circuitry
which switches on and on on and off I
think the parts of this larger circuitry
and then perhaps you know the talamo's
will come in as I haven't even suggested
the thalamus is an important part of
modeling cortex yet because to me this
may be very naive I think models of
cortex can be very well executed with
just an input
I can't you're telling us that maybe
turn on or off but my the issues I'm
trying to raise is what happens within
circuitry when you do two things you
bring in a different kind of post
synaptic response and you have two very
different kinds of strengths of
excitatory inputs and the the evidence
from the mouse is that if you plot
synaptic strength by the size of the
epsps or by the probability of release
which is another way to measure it the
glutamatergic inputs are by modely
distributed there's a small peak that is
very act that has very high probability
of release as depression and very strong
epsps at a larger more spread-out one
that is the opposite and I don't know
I'm not sure how useful that idea is but
I think it eventually to understand
cortex those ideas should be
incorporated
[Applause]
Wow